like some people they play Russian
roulette with this pill yet they
literally skip four days and they're
like four pills in and then they get
pregnant and then they send you know
like if I don't choose to keep the child
you know like that's the thing and also
like I feel like a lot of people get
their emotions caught up in this thing
like let's say yeah you're with your
boyfriend you know it's been cheating
and then you get pregnant and then your
emotions get involved you're like oh but
he's so cute on his good days and then
honest maybe it could work it's never
gonna work because he's been cheating so
or you know if it's just not the ideal
situation then you as a woman
how much is you cannot like it you still
choose to have the baby even though the
situation is not perfect